eh bien je prends l'antenne moment même
où s'achève l'hymne national français
vous voyez derrière moi le vainqueur
inattendu de ce championnat d'europe de
la gentillesse 1983 le parisien philippe
petits pains on n'osait plus y croire et
pourtant c'est arrivé
un français sur le podium à la première
place on n'avait pas vu ça depuis 1925
c'est un véritable événement je vais
tâcher de m'approcher de philippe besson
attendant je vous propose de regarder un
résumé des principaux moments de cette
soirée sportive célébrités revient ce
matin que dans la très belle salle les
bonnes oeuvres internationales ont
commencé ces jeux par un défilé des
participants très très appliqué
le chanoine cordeliers président de la
fédération internationale de la
gentillesse a déclaré les 35e
championnat ouvert dans une ambiance
sereine les douces et entouré du grand
rabbin gutman et des pasteurs en ville
tous deux juges arbitres c'est par
l'épreuve très sélective tendait l'autre
joue que débute le championnat c'est
l'anglais wilton ici en maillot blanc
qui part grand favori l'italien paolini
envers derrière lui peut-être dangereux
également
voilà les athlètes à présent auprès de
leurs marques
petit pain est un peu tendu on le
comprend il ne part pas gagnant
mais il y croit et c'est ce qui compte
dans ce genre d'épreuve regardez bien la
parfaite position de l'ajout du français
au départ voilà il tend l'autre joué
c'est qu'il prend la tête
et oui le français a gagné à la
stupéfaction générale pâtit pas exulte
lee daniels paolini conteste mais le
français semble n'avoir aucun doute et
il a raison l'italienne ne s'avoue
toujours pas vaincu
quant à l'anglais wilton et c'est la
grosse surprise il est éliminé pour
décrochement de la mâchoire
le ralenti nous montre la victoire
indiscutable du français qui est giflé 3
dixièmes de secondes avant l'italien
paolini sans commentaire monsieur
paolini et puis c'est l'épreuve en bonne
en pays chauds 42 km en courant avec
dans les principaux pays de la
croix-rouge pesant 16 kg nous en sommes
ici au 175e tour c'est le manga strophes
qui est en tête on le sait est
imbattable dans cette épreuve
il faut dire qu'il s'entraîne tout
l'hiver au sahel et au bangladesh après
35 kilomètres il garde toujours son
sourire gentil qui lui vaut un point de
bonification tous les dix tours
rythme est très soutenu et puis à trois
tours de la fin l'italien attaque
toujours encouragé par sa charmante
épouse de skins à petit pas un résiste
bien mais il n'inquiète pas l'italien
qui s'envolent seul vers la victoire
et pourtant regardez bien à 10 mètres de
l'arrivée l'italien chute petits pains
pas gagné non il s'arrête et retourne
sur ses pinces secourir son malheureux
camarades qu'ils aident et réconforte de
son mieux
une fois sans polir et paraît il le
traîne jusqu'à la ligne d'arrivée sous
les vivats de la foule
très bien vu de la part de français car
cet acte extrême gentillesse lui permet
d'être déclaré vainqueur avec 30 points
de bonification dans le camp français on
ne tient plus de joie arbitré par le
rabbin goldman commence la difficile
épreuve coeur sur la main
vous le savez chaque concurrent doit
faire un don un pauvre sur son chéquier
personnel en moins de 15 secondes petit
peu en tête de la compétition à ce
moment entame très confiant cette
épreuve l'italien paolini à deux points
du français espère bien revenir en tête
dernier training
très bonne prise silo de l'italien le
français a raté son départ mais revient
bien à mi parcours on va vite la ligne
comme vous voyez une signature rapide de
petits pas et voilà on remet les chèques
à narvik le français croient qu'une fois
de plus avoir gagné mais emporté par son
élan il a commis une erreur il a fait un
chèque de 40 mille francs et les juges
après délibération considère que ce
n'est plus de la gentillesse mais de la
connerie et on voit ici le triste
panonceau annonçant le verdict le
français bon joueur accepte sa défaite
et il est rétrogradé à la troisième
place ex-aequo avec paolini pour petits
pains tout est art
saluons au passage john tweddle qui fut
l'homme le plus gentil d'europe en 46 49
et 53
et puis c'est la finale l'épreuve reine
le traverse âge de vieilles dames les
italiens par le premier
attention c'est parti bon départ de
paoli dit qu'ils progressent en crabe
pour à la fois faire avancer la vieille
et la protéger de son corps vingt-et-une
secondes à mi parcours c'est un très bon
temps et il finit dans un style très à
l'italienne avec arrêt de voitures par
la voix regardez c'est magnifique
25 secondes 6/10 excellente avantage de
l'italien qui a compris que dans cette
épreuve le style compté autant de la
force petits pains de absolument faire
mieux si le temps porté le titre
les voici concentré s'il vous plaît
mamie
départ 13 à la française c'est parti
petit pain tente le tout pour le tout il
fait une traversée à rodez avec
doublement reste des mains sur le nom de
la vieille pour la rassurer
16 secondes à mi parcours c'est très
très bien
puis j'ai choisi la position de l'oeuf
progressant à reculons pour augmenter
nos héros dynamisme et ainsi gagner de
précieuses secondes et il termine la
française aux sorties d'église s'est pas
triomphe
celui que l'on n'attendait pas à gagner
devant tous les gens qui favori bravo
philippe type 1
alors qui est heureux voilà qu'est ce
que ça fait d'être l'homme le plus
gentil l'europe 80 kw un plaisir un
plaisir à nantes n'a pas été facile vous
avez eu peu bah ouais j'ai passé au
zaïre marquer mais il y avait une
tripotée de salon qui était prêt à tout
pour gagner en eau et surtout l'anglais
et l'allemand
elles perdent [ __ ] si aulas tient
vraiment à huy mois dans le coeur sur la
main j'ai cru que j'allais leur arracher
les parties non mais faut pas charrier
merde
le rosbif là avec sa tronche de
cornemuse mouillée qui me pousse deux
fois du coude alors et puis les juges là
il voit rien les juges ils s'en foutent
1 alors on le cul a aidé à me sauter
dessus tu as du temps et de l'air
philippe philippe le la prochaine étape
le titre mondiale de la gentillesse on
écoute jojo tu vas me lâcher un peu la
guibole avec les questions à la noix
parce que moi je dis news j'ai pas que
ça à faire tu vois tu me laisses passer
n'oublie pas ce qu'il ait claqué une
toiture ou je te passe la tête
sans blague et bien c'est sur cette
image d'un grand champion qui prouve une
fois de plus en france avec du courage
et de la volonté on peut être parmi les
plus gentils d'europe que je vous rend
l'antenne